we're talking about what's old is new
again right with the last dance this
this gentleman's Reno 911 is back the
Comedy Central hit now back with kwibi
and thanks to him in the great crew on
the Odd Couple I got to appear in a
guest star cameo on the TV show of my
youth where he plays Felix Unger
obviously the Tony Randall character and
he was spectacular
in that role the very funny Thomas
Lennon back here in the Rich Eisen show
how are you Thomas rich it is so good to
hear your voice and it was fun too you
know you and I talk about comedy a lot
we talk about a lot of different stuff I
don't know I don't know you know I was
listening to show you know that I'm from
Oak Park I'm from Chicago
I'm from Bulls territory I know that I
know and what I mean I see I definitely
look in the lieutenant dangle outfit and
stuff I know it seemed like a real sort
of musical theater dandy but did you
know that when when the Bulls when the
when the real you know not excuse me not
the real Bulls when the Bulls were
playing yes I've never missed a
televised Bulls game ever if it was on
television I watched it and in fact you
know Ken Marino there one of the other
guys drawers of course sure so we lived
in New York and we were doing the state
and Marino I think is a lot like you he
is a dyed-in-the-wool New York Knicks
fan and if you lived in New York which I
did in the late 80s and the through the
90s you know I didn't need an ATM
machine account because Marino has such
a big mouth and he would always get in
my face everybody in New York too hated
Chicago and we they hate them so much
and it was always a fluke and we always
got very lucky and Camarena would bet me
a hundred dollars every Bulls Knicks
game you know for the entire 90s so and
it was my only source of income so you
and Jordan had at least that in common
where you were taking money from people
when you start talking with New York
people they always get they got to get
you with some kind of no you know but
you look the last dance could be when
it's the Knicks the last laugh and the
thing is I don't how much you've been
watching this documentary about four I
mean number four in I think so excellent
so so then you saw the first couple
where you know Jordan in North Carolina
does what he does is a freshman beating
Patrick Ewing and I I turned a you know
my wife and I turn to my kids and I'm
like it's just he's been standing in
front of you ins place forever I mean
for absolutely ever and ever and ever
and ever and you know you if you want to
talk about people who Jordan prevented
from reaching the pinnacle of their
profession and the the number of
superstar athletes who he did that to
were many Ewing's at the top of the list
there's just no and you know I feel sad
for next fans but also you gotta keep in
mind I made almost $2,400 all over this
thing
I don't know people know go back you can
get it I'm sure many downloads watch
return off the uncomfort hey man Thomas
I'm telling you you know growing up
again
Thomas letting here on the Rich Eisen
show and we will talk about Reno nine
one one and a second because I was
talking about this the other day the
episode of Felix Unger and Oscar Madison
having Howard Cosell on and Monday Night
Football and all but that's my youth you
know what I mean like that is it so when
I got a phone call you know cuz Matthew
Perry put me and go on another an NBC
show I'm like I'm in I'm in to do the
Odd Couple and it was amazing just to
see your rendition of Felix Unger was
spot-on brother you really blew me away
especially because when I heard you were
coming in I was like yeah I'm not that
guy really
man really I'm gonna have to I got I got
a deal with this really this kind like a
real guy gonna be like a macho blowhard
yeah that's man that's me and we've been
very casually friends ever since and I
say that in the biggest air quotes
well you haven't taken money from me
like you did Ken Marino let's put it
that way since that's obviously a metric
Oh God Jordan would come in and all even
the best thing that would happen is
Jordan would come into the garden and
you'd hear hey guess what Jordan's sick
New York and then all of a sudden in New
York people would be like hey Marino and
I'm gonna do a sorry Ken Marino's from
Long Island should be like oh yeah oh
yeah it starts you're gonna get them it
gonna get them at sting so Ken will get
excited cool man yeah Jordan sick that's
fine well let's see what happened if you
want to double it yeah if you haven't
caught up in it sitting on your DVR one
of the episodes from this past weekend
is the 1993 Eastern Conference final
with between the Knicks and the Bulls
where the Bulls are going for their
three-peat and the nickel in the garden
it is the Charles Smith still hasn't
made the bunny basket underneath he's
still I think he's he's now over 3,000
50 right now attempting it still and and
and if if you if if the tears of a
Knicks fan is actually nectar for you
the shots of the stunned Knick fans that
they had in this documentary mimicked my
look on my couch this past weekend it's
a really heavy thing to see but Jordan I
mean look you're Chicago I get sunnier
so Jordan is number one right or where
am I missing somebody from your Cubs
fandom or bears or anything like that no
Jordan the only thing I got a actually
have it set one my dad worked at the art
store Skog oh and he used to have to
kind of glue paintings if they run alone
and he went to Russia and he ended up
getting me one of my most prized
possessions I have a set of rushing
Russian nesting dolls
of the bolts of the of the bulls the
great Bulls lineup so it's amazing can
you walk me through the order of the
nest doll Vanessa can you want to go
okay
okay Jordan yep yep
Rodman yep come on white dude with the
short blonde hair come on Oh secure her
okay and then and then weirdly the
littlest guys the biggest guy like
Russian street corner
you know you know excuse me I guess this
would have been no I think it's post
Gorbachev I really do think one of my
prized possessions I also used to have
this is what kills me yes I used to have
the Dennis Rodman bad as I want to be
doll do you remember when they made the
Dennis Rodman doll so the bad as I wanna
be
Robin it was right when the book came
out and here's what it came with it came
with the 91 Jersey yeah it's a white
Bulls uniform yes though red on white
yes but then it also came with silver
moon boots
you could change his hair from like
regular sort of tight little hairstyle
yes
to pink green and then it so it came
with like weird like Dennis's either on
the court or Dennis's out in a club and
I kept that in the box untouched yes in
the 90s untouched and my wife god bless
her you love her you know Millie from
Boulder run you remember my boy yes yeah
yes so god bless her one day my our son
is little and she's like and I look
around the room and I'm like what I was
so little tiny silver moon boots doing
here in the plane oh and she's like oh
we opened up that that's all of it you
never open up like you're not you didn't
do that wait you know what I I strike
what I said you couldn't just change
Dennis's hair his entire head would swap
so it's suitable for children it's
suitable for children
one yeah one head had like pink hair or
maybe green hair and the glasses and the
other was like normal Dennis head and my
wife I have no idea I'm gonna eBay it
right after we hang up Justin Justin
Google what one in the Box would have
been worth fifty five ed Thomas fifty
five dollars on eBay right he booked it
up you can make a buck hey you make it
Evan
I don't know I think the luc longley
nest-egg doll might be worth more Thomas
Lee because in the offseason by the way
dude a band called luc longley boogie
board incident probably sell out at
least a couple venues in Chicago
absolutely couldn't play it all and
everybody just wanted to kill Thomas
Lennon here on Rich Eisen sure now you
are back with Reno 911 on kwibi which is
congratulations and thank you for
bringing back the show my god you once
did throw out a first pitch in Wrigley
Field dressed in the full-on short
shorts and everything right of
lieutenant dangle correct you did that
yes now was it was that an intense idea
yeah it was happen coincidence which is
WGN you know my honda hometown channel
in the Cubs channel yes they ended up
they syndicated reno 9-1-1
cubs management said hey would you want
to come throw a lot of pitch the dangle
short shorts energy it's centered down
and I gotta say it was a night game at
Wrigley this was cool I as a kid you
know I had never been doing there was no
such thing as in that game sure I was a
kid up in for a long time and you know
night game at Wrigley sold out threw the
pitch a little bit high cuz I didn't
warn you no Cubs management said if you
don't throw it high you are gonna be a
jinx and everybody's going to hate you
yes
it was a little bit high I'm gonna ride
the catching threw the ball to me but it
sounded good it was right over the plate
crowd goes crazy I ran home to my dad
catcher throws me the ball I throw the
ball to my dad I'm gonna start crying
and my dad says a little bit high and if
you ever wonder why your pal tom is like
a little bit crazy
above the letters Thomas your dad said
just never above the letters but it by
the way what are you doing kid that is a
good but you've got a good advice
because if you threw from the mound
normally you're gonna dirt it because
you're gonna throw it up down so to aim
high is probably you did the right thing
the question is to also I mean how do
you throw pitch in those shorts that had
to be snug to say the least it really
didn't feel great you didn't go full
wind-up in those shorts right just
fourth I think you can certainly find
images of it but I did I did my best
full like crazy Tim Robbins Bull Durham
no luck but yeah it certainly didn't
feel good I don't know which I'm sure
you've run out some pictures right I
have thrown one at Dodger Stadium and it
was one of the most nerve-wracking
things I have ever done ever it is it's
it's so just distressing it's almost
hard to explain did you did you shred
your arm the day before practicing well
um actually what I did is I did get to
sneak on Jackie Robinson Stadium on the
campus of UCLA to take some warmups damn
straight I did that my wife was like you
better you better practice because you
know if if you don't perform well on a
first pitch it's on YouTube forever like
your children will have it forever like
oh we just lost them right there that's
the problem by the way we'll get them
back in a second
if you dirt something like remember
Akbar Basha city cent did Britney Spears
dirt one or something right Harry Caray
the mayor of Cincinnati as you can go
down that was the national anthem and
the end of the first pitch fitty cent
did I say to him yeah oh if you botch a
first pitch it's over lives forever it's
over this my first pitch here's how long
ago it was
what you
wasn't my first pitch think it was 13
right
the back-up catcher caught my first
pitch cuz you know again you're not
gonna have it
you know right unless you're certainly
here in Los Angeles if you're not tony
danza you're not getting started right
and the backup catcher though at the
time was Kenley Jansen I was soon to be
converted into all-star closer so I
would like to say I converted him
bababooey has one of the worst ones
exactly so what I did was I practiced
but I did go to the top of the mound
right and I I took my time and I would
have if I'm not mistaken here if I'm is
Thomas back telling my story of when I
threw out a first pitch it was it was
off-speed stuff I would have hit a
right-handed hitter but the left-handed
hitter would have swung over the moving
pitch my off-speed movement it's kind of
like a screwball in a way but not
certainly not not killed just gradually
badly injured exactly hey but before now
that done your back on I do want to talk
quickly or what you wish to say about
reno911.com back together you got the
whole band back together you got Patton
Oswalt's also making some some
appearance it's just amazing what you've
done here Tim Allen came in and played
the guy who's training lieutenant dangle
to go to space space force there's some
cool stuff happens in this season so you
know it was interesting we'd always
talked about you know people people
always you know bug us about not focused
I mean god bless people were always like
hey that was the best thing do more of
those you know mm-hmm it's a little bit
like when you're a band and people are
like hey play the hits I don't want to
hear your new stuff play the hit so
right so you know
one for us is like you know playing The
Greatest Hits I will say you know the
new kwibi format which is some people
don't know a lot some folks are confused
it's a yes it's a strange name I tend to
agree but that said the the the service
is actually pretty neat so originally
I'm talking to you are are you Thomas no
I got dropped before it's okay it's a
you can watch it on your phone and as of
today there's like four Reno 911 ones
but they're the I think the sort of the
news and kind of perfect part of them is
that they're about six and a half to
seven minutes long and I don't think you
will miss anything if you like the old
show and all the idiocy that we were
doing these are all the ingredients are
exactly the same it's just slightly
maybe a little more condensed and a
little more intense there premiered
yesterday on kwibi three episodes
premiered yesterday all new episodes
launching weekdays in the app and and
everyone should go check that out and
then your new released ronan boil and
the swamp of certain death the second
book in your three book series New York
Times bestseller the first of which was
a best-seller Congrats on that tale
products I tell you this rich you know
it's one of those things you know I
thought about like oh man I'm writing a
children's book this will be neat so I
can chill it's like a fun children's
novel you could you can enjoy it as a
grown-up you can enjoy it as a kid if
you like funny stuff you'll like the run
of oil books but you know you know maybe
it's because of you know growing up with
a dad who was like hey that pitch was a
little bit high yes but but you know the
day that you make the the New York Times
bestseller list they called me and
they're like hey you made the New York
Times bestseller list and I can just
tell you that felt good for ready for
this long ready hmm one one thousand two
one thousand and we're done I don't know
you're a grown up my god Thomas you are
a funny man Congrats on the return of
renown
one come back anytime let's let's have
young brother any time my favorite
people to talk to my back at you and
bulls forever and ever and ever so
what's our what's our new Chris what's
our new fantasy team name is it look
Longley boogie board incident or is it
Luc Longley Longley nest-egg Center good
I'm gonna go with luc longley boogie
board just that's it gets good we know
what the avatar will be thanks for
calling Thomas you take care of brother
Thomas Lennon on Twitter check it out
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here